a fox news alert for you a verdict just
in in the case we told you about last
night the case of the murder of st louis
police captain david dorn we are
rejoined by our friend kevin cork who
has the story for us hey kevin yeah
tucker just uh finding out about this
one from the great city of saint louis
city jurors finding stephen cannon
guilty on murder charges first degree
murder charges and several other charges
in the 2020 killing of retired saint
louis police captain david dorn it only
took the jury three hours of
deliberation on the third day of
evidence and testimony
cannon was the real coward in this
circumstance he crouched down and shot
dorne 10 times as looters attempted to
rob lee's jewelry and palm
pawn shop
dorne was 77 years old doing what he
could to get out there and make a living
and try to save this business which was
under attack
he was murdered senselessly tucker
we talked to his widow last night kevin
cork thank you for that update
appreciate it you're welcome
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight